[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous les fans et c'est sa seule télé en
france et chaud chaud il voulait faire
absolument timisoara bmp il a plus de 3
milliards de vues youtube avec migros un
milliard de stream pour l'album culture
tout 27 collaboration 15 mixtape trois
albums alors vous venez ici parce que
c'est la fashion week en ce moment et
des on le voit ilike faire look
d'ailleurs franchement magnifique au
alors ça tu dis oui site et ilike ilike
viol
franchement il alors paris alors vous le
pari que vous aimez paris you like paris
vous venez souvent ici à paris à baie
comeau à la fashion week c'est bien
alors il la fashion week c'est quoi la
fashion week c'est tout aux deux fois
par an il ya les défilés pendant une
semaine très concentré avec dix défilés
se situe à déchirer d'ailleurs cette
semaine vous avez défilé pour pour
qu'elles marquent un arrêt j'étais sur
un point j'ai aussi été à louis vuitton
entre autres un aussi valentino alors je
vais devoir citer d'autres marques bien
ce qui habille petits pas
export de csa sonny boy également et je
suis toujours un homme human voilà bien
sûr monsieur de fursac alors le look
c'est très important pour vous le look
cccc le look c'est tout ce que vous avez
en tant qu'artiste vous devez avoir
votre propre donc un look distinctif
l'un des jeunes a des trucs les plus
importants mais vous savez où vous avez
un vrai look affreux est ce que vous
aimez du lac de look
autour de la table et l'eau chlorée
classique non j'aime bien ça fait mal au
cul ma ghadir ouais c'est pas mal
elle m'a pas qui fait kiffer pantalon
d'homme cette chaussure la guerre
après tout qui veut one bien seul et
dormi amokrane richesses avec plaisir il
y en a dans ma loge amenez-moi pantalon
c'est pour moi j'ai vu on est à peu près
dans la même dans le même temps elle
comment comment vous définiriez votre
votre style en 2000 parce que c'est vrai
que moi je vois là tout le monde peut
pas s'habiller comme gilles verdez avec
ça la c4 à du père noël est une ordure
vous définissez votre sur deux mots
d'une et unique et sélectif unique et c
est ce qui vous inspire dans la mode
joséphine ange gardien le mec qui dit
n'importe quoi qu'est ce qui vous
inspire de la mode les plus grands comme
mick jackson marines aims bouder jean ah
ouais j'aime beaucoup son look c'est
vraiment magnifique s à ça à cette plate
à ces magnifiques locaux liés mais vous
avez raison c'est complètement vas-y à
le collier discret ce dimon c'est la
maison et devrait dire un 100m et
regarder de dounia docteur ça mais tu
ouvres comme ça qu'est ce que tu as well
as the amazing en fait et quand ou bien
un mec qui te brasseur et que j'essaye
[Musique]
vous expliquent ils à demi pardonnée
thank you like you like de montrer des
escaliers ah oui il faut que je montre
les escales double la maison en fait
est ce qu'on peut appeler stéphane plaza
pour faire un câlin franchement j'adore
c'est mon style a offert par contraire
si t'as pas une minerve le lendemain on
a qu'à jeter des merci et surtout qu'est
new kids heures kanye west a acheté
acheta palier à lombez à coke à la
schlague j'ai mis à l'envers alliés mais
je suis vraiment un abruti
ah ouais mais sans la laisser là
[Applaudissements]
je suis sûr que cette maison-là les plus
chers que la maison qu'on a offert est
les plus chers comme un mélo mais nous
tous à dire tarifs de tarifs 6 euros que
soit sa femme chérie c'est bon j'ai
acheté deux maisons pour le foyer on
tire on l'a eue le prêt on a voulu
préparer un défilé pour toi il ya des
jeunes filles qui vont défiler tu va
nous dire laquelle laquelle tu préfères
laquelle quel look tu préfères puisque
elles ont préparé des looks assez
incroyable amiens modèle c'est parti on
y va regarder elle ne veut plus des
filets
[Applaudissements]
novelli qui défilent normalement pour le
salon du chocolat mais l'internet
d'habitude elle dessine pour le salon du
chocolat mais l'aide à la fois la bouffe
et sa robe comme l'avait à la fois la
poupée sa robe elle préfère essayer
quand ça do you like merci là c'est le
jack a dull avait super sat chili c'est
cool ça me permet toutes les marques
versace est illettrée you are entre
évasion news ea c'est très beau ça
franchement bravo bravo ksa on va très
bien attention elle a été plus beaux
élue plus belle femme de france en 2012
regardez c'est delphine wespiser ouais
ouais
[Applaudissements]
on venait d'un marathon doute lire ce
manga death en pro forma bottes au
maquillage et eu les mêmes choses ce
sera une version de la part de michael
jackson à l'époque oui vous en faire ça
ouais et sans rien nous ont soif de
puissance 4 anniversaire toi tu as mal à
les regarder 3ème magasin
elle est venue spécialement du sud de la
france juste pour définir on vous dira
qu'elle a beaucoup de travail on la
surnomme morzini dans le monde entier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en fait elle a juste mis des colliers sa
vie trois modèles ce soir il a il va
choisir quel est son modèle bien sûr de
looks préférés n'ont pas de femmes et de
looks préférés et on a avec nous un
dernier modèle que vous allez s'en
occuper mais c'est un autre style
totalement un autre délire c'est
isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors allez on savait par isabelle aulas
à toutes les tenues sont cool ap mais je
pense que c'est moi qui ait la meilleure
tenue
[Applaudissements]